avec les ans il ya des élèves qui
peuvent pas passer le bac en juin parce
qu'ils sont malades parce qu'ils ont un
accès à condition aussi quelques années
quand mais il fallait quand même super g
crissier de monsieur phoenix avait prévu
j'aimerais qu'on écoute vous est prévu
louie louie louie vous dire merci parce
que vous donnez le meilleur exemple que
ce que tous les bts et tous les
étudiants cherchent à montrer on se
retrouve face à un mur
vous nous demandez limite de vous
remercier de nous donner la logique des
joues ta médiation et les bêtises et
vous donner la région y ait pas être
fier de mon travail j'ai dit ça sans
rien vous souriez ce sourire c'est celui
du mépris qu'on se condamner trois mois
alors qu'on essaye de vous expliquer ya
mille et un problème une solution cette
piscine et ben oui c'est le contrôle
continu pour une seule raison c'est
parce que si vous acceptez contrôle deux
années vous admettez que blanquet
ravoire et simple raison l éthique la
vérité yann accord et ça c'est non mais
quand vous voulez on parle politique
apparemment vous êtes un expert juste
oui je voulais ne sais quoi dans mes
pauses et gad
krainer de problème avec une épreuve
termina est ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que le contrôle
continu c'est-à-dire chaque prof dans
chaque bus qui met ses notes
donc en fait vous avez mais note de
votre établissement des profs vous avez
des wii refait miroir de nos travail
dément d'ailleurs que le fasse car leur
servir mambé que le phare à titre
exceptionnel l'année dernière parce que
c'était très particulier mais attends
savoir si la théorie des sous vêtements
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
quand on a du sens pour cent contre le
continue la valeur du bac est la même
quand vous êtes à saint jean de passy ou
qu'on vous êtes dans un lycée de saint
louis quand vous dites vous pensez que
andouard des cadets situation
particulièrement dramatique
est ce que vous pensez pas est ce que
vous pensez pas que le fait de proposer
des épreuves une ou deux épreuves
finales à des élèves c'est mettre tout
le monde sur le pied d'égalité
soit je vais demander moi motte lycée
quel que soit votre département quelle
que soit votre nom de famille quel que
soit votre adresse là vous êtes non sur
le
d'après la cgt sur des plateaux télé à
vous dire exactement ce que vous êtes en
train de dire sur l'inégalité des notre
établissement vous avez voté parcours
sup
vous tenez exactement le discours
inverse alors